hey guys it's amanda cerny and welcome
to tea time with Cerny this is where I
play tennis and have a QA while playing
tennis with a very special guest and
today's guest is
[Music]
hangout again which I'm super excited
because it's been a minute because
you've been working on your music very
excited for that yes and have you played
tennis before no so I have another
chance of winning let's play all right
ladies I hope you guys are ready I want
to see a clean game Lauren heads or
tails tails tails who saris first I was
hoping it wouldn't be me and my
decisions yeah here we go
I feel like you're faking that it's your
first time but you're really really good
I like hit it before yeah but that's all
you're gonna start like spiking on me
and just like I'm scared too worried me
I know it you're working on your music
now right yeah that can serve yes I am
so um you have a new song coming out
yeah first ever song being released ever
what I remember you talking about this
like like a while back with me oh my god
whoa love-15 you got point touchdown
that's insane I remember like when I was
talking to with you about it before and
you just said you were like waiting cuz
you were oh I know
she's dangerous with that hit just get
it off so you're with your label now
yeah capital capital mm-hmm what's it
like being signed to a record label um
everything it's really cool everyone
works really well together it was out on
me through good ii sir
yeah everyone worked really well
together it's just everything I'd be
doing anyways on a bigger scale yeah
they give you like more production value
and yeah exactly it's awesome
alright I'm gonna ask you a random
question oh shoot haha
3015 what started out simple what what's
your favorite color
favorite color is
eggplant purple or red that's really
specific oh shoot
4015 what's your favorite holiday uh
Halloween why I don't know Christmas is
cliche you don't like gifts I I'm not
doing gifts this year with my family
what are you doing going on vacation to
where oh yeah
game point Amanda that's what I started
doing with my family
yeah cheating yeah so much better that
way
I am last year we went to Aspen as a
family vacation
you won the first one I did yeah already
yeah
whoever gets the three rounds wins oh
you're saying you're probably gonna win
good luck I am a done sports in like
three years
this is where I have to get Lauren out
to hang out with me oh it's like when
are you free can I have you for an hour
those pecs oh shoot
this is so hard all right so you're
starting to go on family vacations yeah
for Christmas instead of you know
Brisbane did you do that loss love-15
sorry gets a little crazy when Lauren
guys in the boat so did you go anywhere
last year um no last year we were just
at my apartment
oh cool and we did gifts and stuff on
the side Lauren we're switching it up
yep okay I think I want to go somewhere
warm this year for Christmas
yeah I think that's what we were
thinking like the Bahamas oh sorry I'm
gonna hit Lorna chance love third okay
I'm losing that quick no oh really well
oh my gosh
most of the collectivity I've done in a
while over here
nice gonna play Oh No you're pullin all
right 15:30 you got it 15:30 mean you
got 15 I got 30 what have you always
been blonde oh yeah yeah hair was white
when I was little
mine too alright 30 all what does that
mean can I win
not yet I have a train up two more
points and you will yeah mine was blonde
and then it turned brown that's what
happened to my dad the struggle second
serve is that out you got to get in the
box
Frick I've been letting them fly
everywhere but that one knows like now
what's your biggest win avoid 30 40
what's my biggest one fear my biggest
fear is drowning dying drowning oh it's
like that's really deep I guess it is
dying because that would suck yeah good
sure that's what people are dying would
say alright who's that what's the score
you won the second game already yep I
surf all right let's get to the juicy
questions okay
how did you come up with the name angels
for your fans um it kind of started I
was like a ton of endearment
is that bad second serve and endearment
yeah and I just kind of liked it and now
I had really done it so I mean I like
being called an angel so I appreciate
the Knightly it's nice to hear yeah not
everybody calls me that what do you call
your fans dreams Ernie
oh yeah I've seen that that was a dump I
got real berated women love I was
calling them sir nation and then I had
like a million names because I'm so
indecisive yeah and then I was just like
I don't know they just know who they are
I feel like um who's your favorite
person on social media besides me out
I'm with the camera 30 loved one I don't
know my favorite person in the world is
Eminem but of course he's good me too
him yeah no one ever said that I like I
remember when I was younger was watching
eight-mile and I thought it was the best
thing in all of his musics with the but
video oh my god we remember that so
freaking good and his lyrics are so
entertained I know every song yeah by
heart we need to like jam out to some mm
100% 3015 isn't it like I'm absolutely
gonna lose at this point well you use
not to win the last this game in the
other two oh right but you're winning as
an individual yes I'm laying the world
bring it on and you're from Philly
Philly I'm from Pittsburgh oh yeah
that's right you're from Pennsylvania
yeah oh very good
your Eagles Eagles like 14 15 crazy
yeah so wait so what team do you like um
well I'm not a big football person but
my dad's Patriots which is weird but see
I was Steelers first then Patriots cuz I
lived in Connecticut yeah my dad likes
Tom Brady yeah well I just roll with
that he's great obviously I'm not really
a sports person I used to have a crush
on him when I was little I was like are
you serious not now babe like when I was
little
yes Giselle Mel ring I don't even have
to ask you the juicy questions you
expose yourself yeah like baby I forget
he's a rough today it's not Johannes
he's right yes yes um I'm gonna remember
all of that what's your best memory
my best memory it would probably be the
first time I ever sang on stage I was on
a social media tour and I kind of did it
last minute
but it kind of helped me get over my
fear of singing in front of people yeah
that's where infinity obviously at this
point in time
like I job Lauren yeah yeah it's super
intimidating I couldn't like I do like
public speaking sometimes so for me like
the first time I ever did it I was so
shaky and then look in front of people
even though you talked to millions
people everyday it's like seeing people
in person is a no-go you actually see
their faces right in for the youth
exactly are you gonna have a tour again
um hopefully well definitely cuz that's
something that's has to happen but I
have to have more music out first you
know yeah that's true
but on this side of Christmas I'm going
to some fun places for promo you should
love Christmas what are you saying
Halloween's your favorite I know you
have a lot of things coming up for
Christmas okay I'm sweating I need a
Beautyblender oh all right is it ovary
one yeah but I do have another question
congratulations well so what's one thing
that your fans would love to know right
now one things that my fans would love
to know well a lot of really special
things are coming really soon that I've
worked really hard on and I'm not good
at tennis I think you're okay that last
one you like got more comfortable yeah
yeah but stay right there I got a gift
for you all right
so Lauren yes since I'm gonna be honest
I got you a gift and because you know
the Angels are thing for you I got you
some movies but they're not um I
couldn't find anything on angels so I
got an alien movie ok I figured that's
close enough to Angel yeah and then a
space movie because aliens in space okay
and then 13 reasons why because I I
don't know they sent those to me in the
mail thank you guys so much for watching
I had an awesome time with Lauren she's
a great tennis player in her own way and
I know she loves her gifts so I'm super
excited about that make sure you guys
comment below like subscribe turn on the
notifications and yeah I'll see you guys
next week oh my god
cool oh wow physical activity can't
really thank you
[Music]